kyle gibson he's had nine starts the
numbers are terrific he's one of the
best pitchers in the american league
right now and you take out the first
star the cra is 150 in his last eight
ready to go
against jose altuve well the eighth
pitch of the at-bat and he goes down
swinging
a strikeout for kyle gibson and this
game starts off with a bag well he's
gonna he's gonna get him with a fastball
right at the bottom of the zone 94 miles
an hour could see the sinking action of
that fastball that's a four-seam
fastball and it stays straight altuve
probably gets a piece of it or puts it
in play the sinking action on that
two-seam fastball made the ball move
right below his bat and he missed it now
michael brantley left-handed hitter oh
two
and this one on the ground weakly
towards second so lack on top of it two
up two down one and one yeah they just
you just don't want to face him right
now
hard ground ball second base solace
there again and it's a one two three top
of the first inning for the rangers ace
the first appearance for tyler ivy on a
big league diamond 25 year old right
hander is going to be making his major
league debut right here against a team
he grew up watching third round pick in
2017 and grew up in raleigh texas 30
miles from arlington so he's probably
got a lot of family and friends in town
probably the biggest scouting report
he's got is just relax big moment for
tyler ivey now making his major league
debut against willie calhoun
and gets a fly ball to shallow center
field the first batter he faces
miles straw looks into the closed roof
and puts it away for route number one
ahead of the count owen one
breaking ball is roped into right field
and kyle tucker is there to put it away
three fly ball outs and in the first
inning dad john mom michelle fired up
about the first inning for tyler ivey a
one two three inning against the ranger
remember third less than two outs
looking for something you can elevate
but it's gonna be tough against gibson
there it is ground ball towards holt
throws the second for one diaz safe at
first base beats the double play turn
and the astros score a run oled miss
getting down the line just past enough
to give the astros a one nothing lead
that is a hustle rbi for led miss diaz
good for him kyle gibson getting a ton
of ground ball double plays the rangers
try to turn that one right there but
between
holt and solak not enough to get a lead
miss
speeding down that line and legging it
out brockhold had to back up a couple of
steps to get that big hop and that might
have been that extra time that allowed
to let miss diaz to get there more
double plays and dues than any pitcher
in baseball since 2014. dallas kykel
next on the list about 10 behind kyle
gibson dahl waiting for a 1-2
there's a cold third strike save the
baseball jason castro that is the first
strikeout in the career of tyler ivy
astros lead one nothing
we are through two hey
john ivey is fired up in the stand don't
mess with him at the bottom third
beginning with isaiah keiner for left on
the pitch diving stopped by altuve and
the throw in time to get isaiah kinder
falefa how about the play of jose altuva
on this road trip that was another one
of a maybe four or five outstanding
defensive plays let's hope we look back
at this one and say that it was a great
play in this game all-state good hands
play right here moving to his right on a
hop that was a one-hot line drive that
altuve laid out for that's the good
hands right there but how about on the
other end spike that throw and julie
able to stay with it keep that foot on
the bag and pick that for that great out
brock holt now great to have hold back
activated off the injured list today
ball hit well deep out to right it is
gone
brock holt is back with a home run
and this game tied to one up first day
back first home run of the season ivy
and his big league debut for houston a
1-1 game two men on adolesce garcia
garcia shoots that one out to the alley
right field it gets down base hit low
scores easily gallow got a good start
from first they'll wait into the play he
scores heading to third and garcia
thrown out trying to make it into a
triple the rangers take a 3-1 lead on
the garcia double kinder philippa he's
in scoring position with two outs the
rangers lead three to one swinging a
miss that gets by the catcher they're
going to make a play with kinder
philippa turning around third too far
castro running him back to the bag and
kinder felefa out on the tag by oled
miss diaz all kinds of stuff happening a
strikeout going back to the backstop and
tyler ivey actually made a heads up play
to get connor palefa coming around third
tyler ivy major league debut now in the
books gives way to tip the manual
and this one up the middle that's a base
hit trevino started at second he'll be
waived in to score rangers on top four
to one rbi single for nate lowe that
gives him 27
runs batted in this year now gibson nice
job again tonight first opportunity say
hello to carlos correa 3-2 pitch strike
three call correa goes down looking and
gibson gets to the sixth inning another
quality start six innings one run on
four hits nine straight quality starts
he joins darvish kenny rogers gaylord
perry only in franchise history to go
nine in a row carlos correa bats for the
second time
hits this one down the line and right
that'll be a fair ball going into the
corner bouncing away from joey gallo
being waved around third as kyle tucker
he is going to score correa and rbi
double the astros within two it's now a
four to two game now the tying run at
the plate jason castro
swing down the left field line fair ball
correa around third he's gonna score
jason castro an rbi double he shoots one
down the line on a couple of hops and
the astros within a run is four to three
castro on second base two out now two
bay
now tube a line drive base hit to left
center field that'll score castro and
tie the game at four jose altuve a
15-game hitting streak
second longest of his career and we're
all knotted up in the eighth and now
jose altube bats with first and second
and one out
altuve grounds one diving stopped by
holt the throw is low and into right
field correa will score straw heading to
third he'll be held up astros take the
5-4 lead in the 10th inning tying run
still at third the winning run now at
first base and adolesce garcia to the
plate
and that's in the air out to right field
tucker is back to the wall
how about a big fella
a three run
and the rangers walk it off in the 10th
inning
the great bombino comes through again
[Applause]